hey everybody is Charlie so VidCon is
happening right now YouTube just
announced like a whole bunch of platform
changes so this is going to be like an
informational video this gonna be like a
breakdown of all the new stuff and some
of the stuff that I'm getting ready to
do on my channel like some of the stuff
that you guys should look out for so
like one of the biggest things that
happened at VidCon this weekend was that
youtube rolled out like they're there 10
million subscriber reward it's a diamond
play button I want to see someone wear
that around their neck there are only
about 35 channels in the world right now
that have 10 million or more subscribers
there were only four or five of those
people that were actually at VidCon and
some of the channels that are there that
big are run by big companies but it
always makes me really happy when I see
that like some of the biggest youtubers
in the world are still just like normal
people that they're like a crap ton of
vevo channels that I just I try to
ignore sometimes it's easy to forget
that there's just like like a crap ton
of like corporate spam all over YouTube
far and away like my favorite part about
YouTube is like individual creators not
not even like big channels just like
watching people that are really
passionate about stuff if you're someone
who makes YouTube videos and you don't
know what crater rewards are whenever
you get a hundred thousand subscribers
YouTube sends you this like this silver
play button I think I got mine sometime
it was like early last year I can't
remember exactly but then like the next
big tears when you hit a million
subscribers you get a goal you get like
a gold version of this which is like a
little bit bigger and then you get the
diamond one which is like it's not quite
bigger but it weighs like a ton more but
big enough to give you like neck
problems if you wore it around a chain I
don't think I did any like you know big
like crazy celebrations whenever
whenever I hit 100,000 subscribers so
I'll try to do something crazy whenever
I hit a million hopefully it'll it'll
happen sometime around the flash vs air
around flare this year so there'll be
some crazy stuff going on around like
note november december this year and
it's all due to you guys so i'm actually
i'm trying to find like really cool
stuff to give away like I don't have any
t-shirts or anything like that but
eventually there'll be some of that
stuff and then I'll also have some
people to help me out so I can spend
less of my time cutting all the derps
out of the the videos that I make and
just spend more time like talking to you
guys in the comments most of my time
like when I when I make a video you know
it'll take me like say like 40 minutes
to record and I'll cut it down to like
10 minutes or whatever it's just a lot
of like cutting derps out but the other
really big thing that YouTube just
changed is that they rolled out new apps
for everyone's
phones now they start with Android
because google owns Android so they're
going to start with our own platform
first at any time they make something
nice and shiny so if you do have an
android phone be sure to update your
YouTube app they made it so that it's
easier to find your subscriptions tab
like like the the homepage whenever you
log in it's called the home screen it's
just like a nightmare right now so
usually I just advise everyone just a
tab over to my subscriptions anybody who
is on YouTube before like 2012-2013
knows what I'm talking about we want our
subscription grid back but they also
streamlined the way alerts work they
work way better now so what you do is
like whenever you navigate to my YouTube
page on mobile even if you're on an
iphone or a windows phone there's like a
little bell here when the bell is grayed
out like when it's when it's like this
it will send you alerts whenever I
upload a video it's probably the most
helpful thing you can have even if you
don't watch videos on your mobile phone
but most of my time is spent on desktop
just because you know I spend all my
time editing in premiere and photoshop
and all that stuff so if you're confused
about how YouTube let you know whenever
I upload videos just ask me questions in
the comments below just because like
like the home page itself isn't really
great about telling you when people
upload videos you have to go to the my
subscriptions tab I've been uploading
videos at 1440p like the regular videos
like not just my videogame videos it
does really weird things with youtube so
i might go back down to 1080 because
i've seen a lot of derps during the
upload process usually what happens is
is at least twice a year like 22
different like big times during the year
youtube rolls out massive changes
massive updates to its platform and
everything breaks for like a couple days
and then it goes back to normal so if i
go back to like 1080p videos you guys
will understand why the next like couple
big things that i want you guys to start
getting ready for like um it'll start
happening in August is fear the walking
dead that's like you know Walking Dead
universe in Doctor Who if you have
absolutely no idea what's going on with
those shows like you've never watched
them before I do make a couple beginners
guides so i'll post some links in the
description there are a couple TV
companies behind some of the videos that
i do like some of the fandoms that i do
that i'm talking to about doing
integration so there might be like cool
stuff for giveaways coming this fall but
i don't want to say anything until those
deals are done but if you see me giving
away a bunch of like Game of Thrones
books or like Game of Thrones
merchandise bore
stuff like that you'll understand why
you'd actually be surprised like the
number of like really official people
you know behind TV networks and films
that actually watch youtube videos I'm
still kind of figuring out how to deal
with all that stuff but anytime anything
like really cool happens I will let you
guys know most of my excitement right
now is for like all of TV to come back
in September in October but the other
really big thing that I'm working on is
like I've started to look for a new
apartment so that I can actually have
like a bigger youtube so i can actually
like a real youtube set the funny thing
is is it probably just look like a
shinier version of this right now this
takes up about half of my apartment I
know you guys can't see but my kitchen
is like right behind the camera so it's
like it's a little cramped that's not
going to happen for a while though it'll
be like late November early December
before I find a new arrow cave or
whatever end up deciding to call it but
it is like the number one thing that I
waste time thinking about you know in it
in addition to like what's going on with
jon snow in season 6 i'll say thank you
to everyone for your love on the game
channel like I've been trying to post
more video game videos but Comic Con
really like put a dent in that just
because there was so much stuff that I
had to get through so there should be
videogame videos coming back pretty soon
I need to finish up Arkham Knights that
I can start playing game of Thrones
episode 5 one of my other big goals this
year in addition to moving to like a
bigger Batcave is finding a spare editor
to help me cut down all my derps so once
my emergency awesome squad grows just
like a little bit you should start
seeing a lot more regular video game
videos because really like if I didn't
have anything else to do like I would
just be playing video games that is like
my favorite thing to do outside of like
reading checking out comic books or
watching movies so until we get to the
end of August my video schedule is going
to be about the same like about what it
is now so like Tuesdays Wednesdays flash
arrow stuff Marvel stuff in between
movie videos after that you know walking
dead game of thrones on Sundays like
pretty normal stuff like if you just
leave you scan back through my videos
like on my video page you know you get a
pretty good idea and for those that
don't know like there are links for like
all my social like Instagram Facebook
Twitter like all the other places that I
like to waste time posting funny stuff
those are up at the top of my channel i
mean i also i also put them at the
bottom of all my descriptions but like
most people don't open the description
tab like they don't like scroll down so
you don't see it so there's a lot of
really awesome video stuff that's going
to be coming in a lot of stuff like you
know outside of the videos
in real life that's going to be going on
too so be sure to subscribe to get
everything in case I haven't mentioned
it before like all the giveaways like
the normal giveaways that i do those
will keep going on each week so like if
you're wondering when the next giveaway
is going to happen just check out like
the latest video for like any given
thing that i've done usually usually I
try to mention something if there any
like special quest that you guys want
though just leave them in the comments
usually I have a pretty good idea based
on the questions you guys ask on each
video like what what you want to talk
about next but I am always down to do
video requests I've seen some of you
guys on Twitter and Facebook asking me
to do a pixels review but that movie is
just the worst thing ever so unless you
love seeing really terrible movies you
can just avoid it I did say something
about seeing it on Twitter I would say
like you know ninety percent of my
tweets are like joke tweets sometimes
it's like it's hard to tell whether
someone is like trying to tell a joke on
Twitter or whether they're being like
super serious so if you ever wondered
like most of the stuff i post on twitter
is either like video updates or me just
having fun so later today i'm going to
be posting a game of thrones video about
Jaime Lannister and his history just you
know stuff from his past like when he
was wait wait younger so you can click
here to get ready for that I should be
posting that video like a couple hours
probably and you can click here to learn
all about like the history of the Robins
in the Batman comics along with the
Suicide Squad movie and Batman V
Superman thank you so much for watching
everybody you're totally awesome let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you